[Musica]
immaginatevi in riva al mare
lo sguardo all'orizzonte
in lontananza scorgete una nave e carica
di passeggeri
sta fondando
la prima cosa che penserete sarà
Oddio povera gente che tragedia che sta
cadendo
Ma la seconda
molto probabilmente sarà per fortuna che
io non sono su quella nave che bello che
essere qui una terra ferma che fortunato
che sono
Ecco questa figura retorica si chiama
naufragio con spettatore ci ricorda che
è molto molto difficile ragionare in
assenza totale di ego Ma se ci pensate e
la natura stessa che ci ha resi egoisti
si chiama istinto di sopravvivenza
Paradossalmente quando siamo dinanzi a
una questione di vita o di morte abbiamo
il meglio di noi per procurarci un
vantaggio Anche a scapito degli altri
Ma la natura ha pensato a questa
selezione naturale con un fine molto più
nobile perché non è tanto importante
la sopravvivenza del singolo individuo
quanto quella della specie anzi più che
sopravvivenza chiamiamolo Progresso
perché selezionando i tratti migliori in
sostanza la specie diventa più
resiliente e quindi molto difficile
effettuare una lettura etica del
concetto di ego perché da una parte
abbiamo questa forza Brutale immediata
individualistica che ci porta a volere e
sopravvivere ma dall'altra abbiamo un
fine più grande
potremmo addirittura azzardarci e
chiamare l'ego un vero e proprio motore
del Progresso ci piace l'idea di
contribuire
a creare nuove idee ci piace l'idea di
contaminarci con dei pensieri ci piace
l'idea di far parte ciascuno di noi nel
nostro piccolo un po' del Progresso
e questa è una bellissima cosa perché ci
dimostra che anche in assenza totale di
una minaccia vera di vita o di morte noi
conserviamo questa tendenza al
miglioramento
C'è un problema però
Non è che con la scusa
di voler contribuire al Progresso del
mondo possiamo fare proprio tutto quello
che ci pare
la vita
è piena di contraddizioni è come se ci
venisse chiesto di essere
buoni o cattivi di seguire un fronte o
un altro fronte di essere egoisti
poetici egoisti o Altruisti
sono come le due mani
di una marionetta che muovono i fili di
questa marionetta qui attaccata da una
parte abbiamo le forze più egoiste più
individualiste dall'altra abbiamo quelle
più altruistiche Ecco pensate
a questa marionetta a cui è
indissolubilmente attaccata
se queste due mani non vanno d'accordo
come che la facciamo muovere la facciamo
muovere in maniera disordinata
Ma se riuscissimo a far andare d'accordo
queste due forze in apparente
contrapposizione la marionetta potremmo
addirittura farla danzare
come facciamo
a far andare d'accordo in sostanza
queste due
forze contrapposte come facciamo beh
potremmo usare un metodo di ragionamento
che viene da molto lontano
dai tempi degli antichi filosofi la
dialettica tutti i filosofi
dell'antichità Platone Socrate
Aristotele Hegel Kant hanno un loro
personalissima
interpretazione
della dialettica
ma tutte le dialetti che hanno un tratto
in comune ci richiede la dialettica per
dare valore hanno idea quindi validarla
di metterla prima in discussione
A differenza della retorica in sostanza
è l'arte di voler avere sempre ragione
la dialettica è l'arte di mettere in
discussione il proprio Ego Come si
ragiona dialetticamente
la dialettica ci richiede Prima di tutto
di prendere un'idea
spezzettarla in tante piccole parti così
che forse cominciamo a vedere
Effettivamente
Quale di questi pali di queste parti
sono effettivamente il cuore della
nostra idea cosa invece sono chiamiamoli
dei refusi forse anche di questo nostro
istinto di sopravvivenza che ci rende
appunto Più che altro individualisti una
volta che abbiamo fatto questa
scrematura ci chiede di fare la stessa
cosa in sostanza con le idee degli altri
che riteniamo
o molto simili o anche in diretta
contrapposizione la dialettica Ceca ci
chiede alla fine di fare una sintesi e
arrivare a portare sul piatto un'idea
che sia sia ancora nostra nell'essenza
Ma che allo stesso tempo contenga un
pochino anzi più che un pochino le parti
migliori deride anche degli altri vedete
questa chiamiamola questa analogia con
l'istintori sopravvivenza dove c'è una
conservazione In sostanza del nostro
desiderio di fare qualcosa prima di
tutto per noi stessi in un certo senso
per
assicurarci la nostra sopravvivenza ma
lo stesso tempo che possa contribuire
questa nostra idea a un fine più grande
che non sia solo il nostro
è tutta una questione di equilibrio come
la metafora della Marionetta In sostanza
Ma come facciamo a tenere il nostro Ego
a vada in modo che non prevalga
conservando comunque
questa sensazione di appagamento che ci
può dare qualcosa fatto per noi appunto
per metterci in salvo
Ecco il tema di quest'anno è energetica
utilizzo etico e aggiungerei consapevole
dell'energia siamo 8 miliardi ormai
diciamo che il mondo ci sta chiedendo in
maniera molto educata in alcuni casi in
altri un po' meno di essere un po' più
selettivi con quello che decidiamo di
fare io Allora ho pensato di raccontarvi
In sostanza
quattro trucchi mentali per tenere a
bada questo Ego Il primo è la metafora
Ve l'ho già fatta è quella della
Marionetta no
Ecco la metafora a parer mio è un
potentissimo strumento di controllo
dell'ego perché in un certo senso quando
noi riusciamo a rendere un'idea una
metafora le Stiamo togliendo il
vestitino il vestitino fatto delle
nostre paure delle nostre contesto della
nostra aspettativa delle nostre speranze
e la diamo in mano o magari
nell'orecchio dell'ascoltatore in
maniera più leggera così che lui possa
prendere inserirvi le sue paure le sue
aspettative e le sue speranze Ecco
un'idea comunicata per metafora Prima di
tutto si riesce a essere capita
dall'altra parte e se ne viene capito il
valore in un certo senso già ci fa
capire che siamo a metà strada che
abbiamo fatto un buon lavoro per
prendere la nostra idea e renderla più
fruibile se noi togliamo la dialettica
dal concetto di metafora diventa
praticamente una storiella per bambini
ma metà metaforicamente parlando La
metafora è un vero e proprio atto etico
dove abbiamo Guardate ancora una volta
questa analogia un perfetto equilibrio
tra il sé e la rinuncia del test
secondo trucco l'inferenza cos'è
l'inferenza l'inferenza L'arte di trarre
conclusioni senza avere a disposizione
tutte le informazioni necessarie per
giudicare nel campo del terzo Come si
ragiona per inferenza si prende un'idea
per la quale siamo chiamati a dare un
parere che però non c'è del tutto
familiare Si risale nell'albero delle
conoscenze fino a fermarci Dove troviamo
qualcosa
diciamo a noi familiare quindi per il
quale possiamo addirittura azzardarci a
dire che siamo certi della nostra presa
di posizione Ecco da lì ci riscende in
questo albero delle idee fino a toccare
di nuovo questa idea che non c'è molto
chiara però con una porta consapevolezza
che stiamo giocando nel campo
dell'incerto
Ecco pensate la lingua italiana quanto è
bella che a volte ci aiuta con dei
giochi di parole di estrema significanza
essere certi sapere di supporre ci rende
Paradossalmente molto meno supponenti
vedete ancora una volta abbiamo in un
certo senso un equilibrio perché
vogliamo dire la nostra anche se magari
non ne abbiamo in un certo senso il
diritto però il fatto di ammettere le
mani avanti e eticamente dire questa è
solo la mia posizione Aiutatemi a
integrarla ci rende in un certo senso o
meno centrati terzo trucco il caos o
meglio
l'accettazione del caos
cos'è il caos possiamo chiamarlo caos
caso fortuna sfortuna fato destino
fenomeno quantistico io
Fatto sta che il caos è un vero e
proprio motore evolutivo rappresenta
l'intangibile l'intoccabile tutto ciò
che non possiamo controllare
l'imprevedibile
vogliamo usare una metafora è come la
spinta giù dal burrone anche se abbiamo
tirato il freno a mano
ma siamo davvero sicuri
Che caos voglia dire fortuna
ecco
mio pensiero che ci può aiutare o almeno
a me aiuta un po' di più a temere di
meno il caos
facciamo finta di
dividere il nostro destino in due parti
metà responsabilità nostra facciamo
anche finta di essere molto bravi e
essere così diligenti dal gestire questa
metà in mano noi che in un certo senso
sia sempre a nostro favore quindi 50%
facciamo che è fortuna l'altro 50% lo
diamo in mano al caos
però
non abbiamo appena detto che la vita è
piena di contraddizione ci sono sempre
alla fine queste due forze estreme che
ci tirano da una parte e dall'altra con
alla fine Col tentativo di fare cose di
portarci in mezzo il caos stesso non è a
questo punto un banalissimo fenomeno
binario in un certo senso vi ho appena
Resi il 25 per cento che fortunati
perché se abbiamo queste forze in
contrapposizione qualche volta senza
neanche volerla controllare ci daranno
anche una spintarella in avanti e non ci
tireranno sempre indietro e anche se
dovessimo cascare in questo sfortunato
25 per cento che sentiamo a nostro
sfavore
forse che sia l'occasione per sentirci
un pochino meno al centro del mondo e
pensare che magari una nostra piccola
sfortuna potrebbe essere
nient'altro che il disegno più grande
quello che abbiamo detto dell'istintori
sopravvivenza che è più interessato In
sostanza al tutto
quarto e ultimo trucco lo smarrimento o
meglio la gestione dello smarrimento
Cos'è che può succedere
fatto tutto questo bellissimo
ragionamento dialettico che una mattina
ci svegliamo e diciamo io non ho capito
niente Non sto effettivamente agendo per
gli altri sono egoista sono un fifone
Cosa faccio Mi fermo Ecco questa si
chiama insicurezza l'insicurezza È
un'arma a doppio taglio perché da un
punto di vista ci può permettere di
metterci più in discussione quindi forse
di fare un passo indietro dal nostro
palco
Ma se ci pervade l'anima noi diventiamo
immobili e senza muoversi Dove sta il
progresso magari lo fanno gli altri ma
non noi dove che è soddisfatta la nostra
parte egoistica di queste forze Ecco noi
abbiamo parlato di dialettica come di
uno strumento di controllo dell'ego non
di
suo come dire
repressione ecco
quindi forse nel momento in cui ci
sentiamo insicuri è il momento di
liberarlo questo Ego vogliamo fare
un'altra metafora
è come aprire la gabbia del leone ma
solo dopo averlo spammato
volete un esempio concreto di
ce l'avete qui davanti perché pensate
visto parlando di controllo dell'ego ma
da dov'è che lo sto facendo da un palco
peraltro in un momento in cui io posso
parlare e voi no pensate all'ipocrisia
di questa cosa dove sta la dialettica in
tutto ciò
Beh allora la parte più egoistica quella
che ho liberato Quella che mi ha fatto
fare il passo per arrivare sul palco In
sostanza è quella che mi fa dire Vabbè
ma che male c'è a fare un po' di
spettacolo la parte più altruistica più
etica se vogliamo azzardarci a chiamarla
così è quella che adesso mi fa dire a
voi Guardate che prima di tutto io non
vi sto dando nessuna risposta ma mi sto
Condividendo le domande che io stesso mi
sono fatto Senza nessuna pretesa che voi
prendiate queste mie idee e le facciate
vostre Se però volete a vostra totale
d'iscrizione questo può essere
dialetticamente parlando quella parte di
apertura del vostro pensiero a quello di
qualcun altro
le parti ovviamente si devono invertire
vero che ce ne sia occasione
ma ho una bellissima notizia tutto
questo processo tutte queste
informazioni tutti questi trucchi così
complicati in realtà Voi li sapete già
fare e anche molto bene perché la natura
ci ha dato un istinto ci ha dato
un'emozione che celebra il connubio tra
ego e altruismo traigo ed etica traego e
annullamento Diego
si chiama amore
perché quello vero
è assolutamente privo di aspettativa e
molto generoso e molto molto paziente
l'amore forse l'unico sentimento che al
contempo
ci permette di rinunciare a noi stessi
ma sentirci ancora i protagonisti
E allora proviamo a fare una lettura del
concetto di etica Alla luce di tutto
Questo ragionamento
ma forse l'etica e la dialettica in sé
non sono
altro che l'amore stesso per il mondo
delle idee
Grazie
[Applauso]